well it's finally here uh it's been so
long
and yet the last four years in a sense
have flown by it's election day and i
could say
many different things today and if i
said anything
targeted at affecting how or whether you
vote
it would likely be too late because most
people have already voted with
early voting and absentee ballots and by
the time today's show goes out
my guess is something like 95 percent
will have already voted just remaining
with the last few to vote in person in
the second half of today
and the reality is that at this point
this election has been decided
we won't know the results until the
ballots are counted
hopefully every single ballot will be
counted
that's an entire other issue that we've
been dealing with this election
but this is one of the largest
inflection points
not just in american but in global
politics
that i've lived through and certainly
the biggest inflection point that i've
covered
since starting the david pakman show
years and years ago
it is not just the presidency that is up
for grabs tonight
yes in a literal sense it is also the
senate
uh we don't know whether republicans
will retain control
or not it is also the house of
representatives although democrats are
not just expected to retain control
there but even to expand the democratic
majority in the house of representatives
but it is really i i don't want to be
hyperbolic but there's
and i'm not but it sounds like
hyperbolic language
the next 10 to 20 years of american
politics
and global politics i believe are tied
up
in the results today that we will start
to get tonight
the future of the united states as
either
part of the solution or part of the
problem
on climate depends on whether donald
trump gets reelected today
and whether democrats take the senate
today the future of the american
reputation and by extension
the experience that all of us have in
the world
both when we are in the united states
and when we travel elsewhere that is at
stake today
and also at stake today is whether we
start to disassemble
this mind virus that is trumpism or
whether
it is reinforced and perpetuated
over the next four years which would be
an uh
unconscionable disaster donald trump
is uniquely unqualified to be president
of the united states
at any time but there could be no worse
time for such an unqualified and
incompetent president than right now
we've been faced with a hundred year
global pandemic
any other american president from the
last hundred years
would have better handled this pandemic
and in fact
i would suggest that just about
any thinking person would have better
handled this
pandemic by stepping aside and saying i
know enough to know
when i don't know and i'm going to let
the experts handle this
it's almost as if saying nothing and
just saying i'm going to let other
people handle handle it would have been
better and in fact
it would have been better and donald
trump deserves to be
powerfully repudiated and removed
because of his mishandling of the
pandemic
we are rapidly approaching a record
hurricane season caused by many things
one component of which is believed to be
warmer oceans
partially as a result of american and
human activity on planet earth it is the
united states as a polluter it is humans
as polluters
that is a factor in this worse
potentially worse than ever hurricane
season and we have a president
who has said climate change is a chinese
hoax
meant to bolster the chinese
manufacturing industry
we have an economic crisis which will
likely
get worse before it gets better with the
third spike of coronavirus coming in the
united states
and we have a president who knows
nothing about economics
who called his later to be indicted
national security
adviser in the middle of the night to
say hey is a strong dollar
good or bad for the united states that's
who is handling
the economic situation we've had great
depression like unemployment numbers
gdp declines that even with the partial
recovery of the third quarter
leave us eight percent shy of where we
were at the start of the pandemic
eight percent when you talk about gdp is
a monstrous number
and we have a global community that
started by laughing at us
but they're not laughing anymore they
are actually scared
and pitying us listen to the foreign
callers
who called into my streams over the last
week from austria and argentina
and australia and spain the united
kingdom france
where else many many places they are
scared of trump
and they fear for our futures there
would be no time in american history
where donald trump would have been a
good president
but there are times in american history
where he could have been
a more benign annoyance there is no time
in american history worse than right now
for a president that has so weaponized
the worst of the electorate
and has so coalesced the most disgusting
and violent instances of the american
right wing
we tried the businessman president mitt
romney tried to do it
and the country very soundly said no
we are re-electing barack obama we now
tried the businessman president and it
failed
bad relationships need a clean end and
we can elect a different
spouse today for lack of a better term
and get a clean break on january 20th
you don't usually get the divorce and
the new marriage on the same day
but we actually have that opportunity i
don't know who's ultimately going to win
tonight
i don't know when we will ultimately
know the results and win or lose tonight
unless we fix our education our culture
of our financial systems we aren't going
to fix the problem of 30
40 50 60 million people who not only
voted for donald trump four years ago
but after seeing what he did for the
last four years said give me another
four
okay trumpism does not disappear with
trump
whether he leaves in two and a half
months or
four years and two and a half months if
there are no consequences
for the disgusting bad faith politics
that we've seen this cycle
and in fact if we don't deal with that
it could continue indefinitely
it could even be the downfall of the
country and i know many will say
the united states could never have a
downfall it's too powerful
every empire in the midst
would say we will last forever and
just about every such empire did
eventually fall
but we're getting ahead of ourselves did
you vote
is the is the answer yes if the answer
is yes
uh then you've done your part did you
tell people
you should vote and here's why you
should vote for joe biden or some
combination some version of that
we have to be okay knowing we've done
what we can do we ultimately don't
control the fact that there are more
than 60 million people in this country
likely to vote
vote to re-elect donald trump but for
today the focus is
let's remove trump let's take control of
the senate back
let's open the door to starting to fix
some of these issues
the counterpoint the alternative is very
ugly
and it's not clear to me that our
democracy can withstand another four
years of trump the country
will withstand four more years of trump
but will our democracy
and by the way another four years of
trump
opens the door to another trump in 2024
it could be literally another trump like
don
trump jr or ivanka trump it could just
be a trump-like republican
both would be a disaster so today is not
about reminding you about bleach
injections
drawing on hurricane maps with sharpies
like the one i have here or lying again
and again and again and again and again
as he has done for so long
this is merely about saying to the world
through the results that we will
hopefully get today
enough of us realize the mistake that
was made in 2016
some of us made a mistake by actually
voting for trump not me
but some of us did some of us made a
mistake by not voting at all
um we realized that mistake and we are
taking not even step one but step 0.5 in
the direction of fix it fixing it we're
trying to get the ball back
to try to put some points on the board
in the next couple of years
i hope everyone in the audience has
voted we will be
hopefully all together tonight as the
results start to come in
we may not know everything by by
midnight tonight but we will know quite
a bit
and we will do our best to get you ready
today for the next 24 hours i will give
you my final predictions
reminder i will be live tonight starting
with the first results at 7 pm eastern
time
we will be monitoring all of the
different networks we will have maps we
will have spreadsheets
we will have memes and songs and calls
and the entire thing so join me tonight
uh on youtube twitch or facebook
let's now get into what i am predicting
we will see tonight